as he does not operate within any
definable branch of government
Ironman presents a potential threat to
the security of both the nation and to
her interests I did however go on to
summarize that the benefits of Iron Man
far outweigh the liabilities into the
existing chain of command I'm not a
joiner but I'll consider Secretary of
Defense if you ask nice I could go on at
show if I may the imagery that's
connected to your report leave it as
somewhat premature to reveal these
images this time colonel I understand
and if you could just narrate those for
us we'd be very grateful intelligence
suggests that the device is seen in
these photos are in fact attempts at
making manned copies of mr. Starks suit
this has been corroborated by our allies
and local intelligence on the ground
indicating that these suits are quite
possibly at this moment operational hold
on a second let me see
oh boy I'm good I come here for screens
I need him time for a little
transparency
let's see what's really going on what is
he doing if you'll direct your attention
to shed screens
I believe that's North Korea Iran no
immediate threat here is that Justin
Hammer hammer Justin you're on TV focus
oh wow yeah I'd say most countries five
ten years away hammer industries 20 it's
working we're safe America is secure you
want my property you can't have it but I
did you a big favor I have successfully
privatized world peace we're adjourned
you've been at the light hey everybody
it's Charlie so we got all this Avengers
force stuff going on but as we start to
find new Easter eggs recontextualized
because of stuff that's been happening
the last couple of years you may have
spotted this illuminati easter egg from
back in iron man 2 which now feels like
a much more real thing given what's
happening with the fox disney deal so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this the movies been out for a
long time so you may have actually
spotted this when Yuri watched it but
it's on his phone there when he's
pulling up the app to take over the
screen and talk about these alternate
suits that are being made by other
countries there's a little app in the
upper right hand corner that says
Illuminati and that's just Kevin Feige
sort of laying in the groundwork for
stuff that may or may not happen in the
future like it's a cool Easter Egg for
the fans but there are things like at
the end of the movie in the post-credits
scene where they're talking about shield
in the Avengers initiative where they
put Black Panther in Wakanda on that map
I'm in a stable and fish relationship
which leads us to believe at this
juncture we'd only like to use you as a
consultant
you can't afford me
then again I will waive my customary
retainer on exchange for a small favor
now originally like they thought that
they might get to black panther
eventually but it was so far away from
them being able to pay that off that you
didn't know like anything could happen
in that eight year time span and talk
about Illuminati I've mentioned this
before but Namor a member of the
Illuminati originally is actually right
here on the map this dot right here is
Atlantis and even though there have been
some distribution problems with them
doing a name or movie that have
prevented him from showing up before
there are a lot of people that think
that we might actually see him in the
next couple of years but just because
they don't have name Ward doesn't mean
they can't do Illuminati even if they
didn't get the x-men through the Disney
deal they already have so many
Illuminati members within the MCU right
now that they could just do their own
version of it like it's always been an
alternate version of the universe just
because they never had those x-men
characters if they didn't get spider-man
they would have done a different version
of Civil War ant-man would have been a
bigger characters they might have
actually used the wasp character so the
other thing about this now too is is
that Yuri watched the scene and
originally it's just Rhodey
talking about how he feels like Iron Man
isn't serving the interests of the
people of the United States but now
given all the movies that we've seen so
far and what we know is coming in phase
four especially with all these x-men
characters you think about that speech
operating outside the government is
basically a template for what the
Illuminati do a shadow version that's
made up of the most powerful members of
the superhero teams inside the Marvel
Universe now that's the comic book
version like we don't know if we're ever
gonna see a movie version of Black Bolt
so who knows what we're gonna do with
the Inhumans because they were sort of
the MCU stand-in for what was going to
be the x-men characters but now that we
have legit x-men we don't really need to
do in humans unless they want to do
something special with them they started
with Namor Tony Stark who is actually
the person that put it together in the
first place Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four Black Bolt of the
Inhumans Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme
in Professor X the only substitution
that I think that they would make to
this is that they just wouldn't do Namor
if they weren't ready to use him as a
character in the MCU you just do every
other character Professor X is really
the linchpin he's the guy you need to
wait for before you could do something
like this but the reason for why Ironman
wanted to create the Illuminati in the
comics is very similar to what
happening the last couple of years and
what we're gonna see in Captain Marvel
and Avengers 4 so what happened is is
inside the Marvel Universe during the
1970s the characters in the wake of what
happened during the kree-skrull war
decided that there were some threats
that were too great for the earth to
handle with just the Avengers or just
the x-men or just the Inhumans or the
people of Wakanda
so Tony Stark wanting to wrap the earth
in a layer of armor wanted to create a
shadow United Nations beholden to no
specific world government to serve the
interests of the entire earth meaning
they would exist in a morally gray area
and make decisions that not everybody
would agree with the whole idea being is
that you have these great people that
are heads of really great hero
organizations doing shady things super
shady things like using the Infinity
Gauntlet to destroy other versions of
Earth during the incursions what's
happening during Captain Marvel we're
getting our version of the kree-skrull
war even though that's going to be 20
plus years ago in this timelines history
Iron Man Doctor Strange the more
powerful Avengers characters will come
out of Avengers 4 remembering everything
that happened between the snap sure in
the way they fix things so they'll
recognize how important it is that they
have heroes working together which is
the foundation for why the Illuminati
exists like some threats are so great
especially you know teasing the threats
for phase 4 and phase 5 so bare minimum
is probably going to be a while before
we see movie like that I would say
Avengers 5 is probably just going to be
New Avengers with whatever the new
roster is going to be we can talk about
that after Avengers 4 then after that
they could build towards an Illuminati
movie then Avengers 7 can be their
Secret Wars movie in the way that
Avengers 1 2 built towards 3 which was
infinity war so MCU Illuminati who do
you want to be on that team if they're
not going to do name war or say like
Black Bolt anytime soon congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner king
Carlton please email me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn about the
Deadpool - deleted Fantastic Four scene
and click here for that Avengers 4 title
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you